borrowed beneath the tenths of the
bailiffs trying to evict them
there are still five climate activists
digging in
the downshaft that is here that was
dropped on top of the tunnel
you see here we have the chamber they
include 48 year old larch maxi
doggedly calling out what officials are
doing
and the methods used to reach the
tunnelers
his worried parents paul and dorothy are
able to stay in touch with their son
underground by phone have you eaten
today
yeah i was just thinking i'm a bit
peckish now i have a little something
for you i go to sleep
have you got water yes yes plenty
oh good oh that's great
it's lovely to hear your voice but
they're so concerned about the operation
they've appealed to the commissioner of
the metropolitan police to intervene
how are you finding all of this
difficult emotional
um you know you worry about their safety
you say you're worried for his his
safety
therefore have you asked him to to stop
no because we wouldn't like asking
a train to stop he's he's doing what he
believes in
i would never have asked him not to do
it because that's why
that's what he want he believes in and
that's what he really wants
feels he must must do really this is
what the environmentalists are trying to
stop
a new high-speed train link between
london and birmingham
its developers hs2 are furious with the
activists
pointing out the courts have refused to
stop the eviction operation
and accusing them of wasting the
resources of the emergency services
during a pandemic but a supporter of the
tunnelers who's worked on previous
evictions
says it's a dangerous situation
protesters
ideally should leave i'm not taking
their side but
it's it's a duty of care or to all those
involved to ensure that this
job is done properly whoever does it has
got to be done properly to reduce the
chance of death
the houston garden protests are now into
their fourth week
the tunnelers are getting their voices
heard but all the while
work continues on hs2 lisa holland sky
news northamptonshire